so this is why when you hear joe biden
call for unity when you hear from
members of the media declaring a bright
new dawn
an era of good feelings yeah no no
i'm sorry you guys are too invested in
destroying your political opposition for
there to be an era of good feelings
i don't believe you i am skeptical of
your calls for unity i think by unity
you mean shut the hell up
and we're not going to shut the hell up
we have no intention of shutting the
hell up
we're not going to stop saying true
things because they don't fit your
narrative kevin roos
we are not going to stop printing
material that happens to be true
even though facebook doesn't like it and
by the way we are not going to be
protecting the tech bros
if the tech bros decide that they are
going to suppress material on behalf
of the kevin ruses and kara swishers and
juggle gambler of the world
we're not going to do that okay this is
a pressure campaign
by the media to shift the nature of
american politics
and you cannot go along with it and we
will not go along with it either
but inside the democratic party that
pressure campaign
is on the march okay that pressure
campaign is not just on the march
inside the the media battle it's on it's
on the march inside the democratic party
the woke have basically declared war on
everyone who is not completely woke
inside the democratic party
rashida to leave in the squad are going
to war against any democrat who suggests
maybe it's a bad idea to alienate
half the american public by calling them
racist sexist and bigots for not liking
socialism
according to politico rashida talib
isn't apologizing for wanting to yank
money away from bad police departments
she has no second thoughts about her
embrace of the black lives matter
movement or for wanting to aggressively
fight climate change
house democrats lost seats instead of
expanding their majority underperforming
expectations across the board
and moderates have pounced on liberals
like talib a pounced pounce
the michigan congresswoman accusing them
of handing conservatives a set of
slogans and policies to scare voters
but to leave and other house
progressives don't want to hear it it
all amounts to unfair blame casting
designed to shame them into staying
quiet they say
right as democrats gain control of the
white house we're not going to be
successful for silencing districts like
mine said to lieb
me not being able to speak on behalf of
many of my neighbors right now many of
which are black
neighbors means me being silenced i
can't be silent you see
if you opposed but she did it to leib's
ridiculous and radical agenda even
inside the democratic party this means
you're a racist
she said we are not interested in unity
that asks people to sacrifice their
freedom and their rights any longer
right so this is the thing she doesn't
want unity with 70 million
americans who voted for trump she
doesn't even want unity with the vast
majority
of the democratic party who did not vote
for rashida talib and she wants
dominance
so do the media they also want dominance
and they will use the same
slurs that they have used against
republicans even against democrats see
this is the beauty of the woke at least
their purity test
applies to their own party in fact
there's a letter that went out yesterday
from new deal strategies the justice
democrats sunrise movement and data for
progress these are some of the most
radical groups inside
the democratic caucus there's a letter
that went out
to various democrats and to the media
what went wrong for congressional
democrats in 2020
their answer was that they didn't go
radical enough
and that if you disagree with them you
are in fact a vicious and horrifying
racist
they say over the last half century
republicans have harnessed strategic
racism to divide the electorate
too often democrats shy away from
conversations about race and keep issues
of economic justice and racial justice
in separate silos republican attacks
levied at democrats this cycle based on
terms like defund the police or
socialism
have become scapegoats for
representatives like abigail spanberg or
conor lam and other senior democrats
not a single democrat progressive or
otherwise argued that democrats should
run primarily on these themes
moreover these attacks will never go
away normal demands for reform from
social movements
the attacks are designed to stoke racial
resentment which is core to the gop's
election strategy
our party should not feed into it
conservative democrats may change the
terms and people we blame in fear year
by year
but democrats must take on the
republican party's divide and conquer
racism head
on and not demobilize our own base
okay so the good news is at least the
woke are attacking even people inside
their own party
so the media have fallen to the woke the
social media have fallen into the woke
the woke are taking on democrats inside
their own party that is the battle of
the future
okay the battle of the future is going
to be over whether you even get to see
the material you want to see
over whether you get to treat your
friends and neighbors as friends and
neighbors this is why
pasting over all of these deep
philosophical conflicts
right conflicts i talk about my book how
to destroy america in three easy steps
go pick it up today
pasting over those deep philosophical
conflicts with grandpa simpson over here
right joe biden it ain't gonna work
it's why the media are militantly
refusing to listen to joe biden when joe
biden is like listen there's a process
and the process will play out
no one no one cares what joe biden has
to say because the battle has moved
beyond joe biden joe biden may have been
a last gasp attempt by democrats
to basically stop the battle from from
raging but joe biden doesn't have the
stones to actually stand up to his own
party
joe biden doesn't have the stones to
tell michelle obama to be quiet when she
says things like
70 million americans are motivated by
hate and chaos and racism
he doesn't have the stones for that
nobody in the democratic party has the
stones for that
and so what this is going to come down
to is a battle to suppress
right the media are going to continue
pushing narratives they know are false
because it justifies their behavior
members of the democratic party are
going to continue to justify
their lies that americans are broadly
speaking racist because it justifies
their strategy
and you are going to be the only people
standing in the breach and we are going
to be standing with you in the breach
that is the battle for the next decade
the battle for the next decade is will
they be able to shut you up
will they be able to tell you that
because you are a racist sexist bigot
homophobe
you need to be shut up will they be able
to say that things that are factually
true are factually false because they do
not agree with their narrative
will they be able to take control of all
the institutions to such an extent that
you are forced not only to be quiet but
to mirror
their political priorities because
here's the thing we went real fast in
this country from
why can't we just have polite
conversations about politics please stop
being so
so militant in your in your pursuit of
conservatism
two silence is violence we went real
fast from one to the other didn't we
the progression went like this you
conservatives you should be more polite
and conservatives are like okay
and then it went to well you shouldn't
just be polite you should shut up right
you should be silent
in fact stay silent for your own safety
and many conservatives because they felt
like they were being browbeat and were
like
i guess okay and now the message is if
you do not literally repeat
the words we are saying to you right now
and agree that they are true
then we will castigate you as an enemy
if you refuse to say right now
president-elect biden because he is not
in fact president-elect biden you are
the enemy if you're used to say
america's systemically racist you are
the enemy if you don't post a black
square on your facebook page
you are the enemy if you refuse to
post the the tautological semantically
overloaded lawn sign on your lawn
you are the enemy that is the battle the
battle for the future is this culture
war
it is the reason trump was elected in
2016 it's the reason why
democrats did not see the the vast
amount of support that not only trump
but republicans across the country had
in 2020. that battle is not going to
abate anytime soon
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button